Hi how you doing? I’m going to teach you
how to make sense of Feynman diagrams,
know what all the squiggly lines mean,
and work out if they are representing
a valid particle interaction or if they
are defying the laws of physics. Ugh.
A Feynman diagram is a picture of what happens
when particles interact with each other.
Particles go in one end, come out
the other, and some stuff happens
in the middle. And to make sense of Feynman
diagrams you need to know three things.
What all the lines and arrows mean.
What all the particles in the standard
model are as well as their special
properties like charge and spin.
What the overall rules are. These are called
conservation rules, but you could call them
in-out rules, as in, you can’t get out a
different amount out than what you put in.
Here’s a Feynman diagram. The lines represent
different particles which are travelling through
space and time which are represented by these
axes. Note that with one dimension of space
we are losing some spatial information here so
these really are schematics of what a particle
interaction looks like rather than an accurate
depiction of our four dimensional reality.
Here’s an example with a little animation to go
with it. Two electrons move towards each other,
exchange a photon, and move
away from each other again,
and that’s what this looks
like as a Feynman diagram.
In this video I’m drawing time going upwards,
but some people draw it going sideways,
which is quite annoying. So, the first thing
when you look at a Feynman diagram is to check
which way time is going, hopefully they tell
you and if they don’t they are bad people.
Drawing time going upwards is the most
common way so that’s what I’m doing here.
Okay that’s the basics, now let’s go onto
part one of the three things we need to know.
What are the squiggly lines.
These are the four kinds of lines,
each corresponding to a kind of particle.
And I can only explain this if I show you
all the particles, so here they are.
These are the fundamental particles of the
Universe that everything is made
of (as far as we know so far).
But why are they organised like this
instead of being organised like this? Ugh.
It’s because some particles share similar
properties so we can group them together.
Kind of like my cheese collection.
The straight lines represent the fermions
which are these particles. These other particles
are all called bosons. Now the difference between
fermions and bosons at a basic level is the
fermions make up the stuff in the universe and
the bosons are how the stuff interacts with each
other and they are called force carriers.
In fact, everything we experience is made of
just these three fermions: the up and down quarks
which make protons and neutrons, and when you add
electrons to protons and neutrons you get atoms,
that we’re made of and everything
is made of and you’re made of.
The bosons, the force carries,
are all the other lines.
We use a squiggly line for the photon, which is
the force carrier for the electromagnetic field,
The spiral lines are for gluons which carry the
strong force that keeps the nucleus of atoms
together and interacts only with these specific
fermions which are called the quarks.
Now onto the weak force. The mediators of the weak
force are the W and Z bosons and are represented
with a dashed line. All particles interact
with the weak force apart from the gluons.
If this is all a bit much to take in don’t worry
I’ve made a companion poster which you can study
in your own time the link in below.
Finally there is the Higgs boson which we
also use a dashed line for. And those are all the
lines. What about gravity the fourth fundamental
force?.
Haha,
we don’t have gravity here.
This is particle physics!
You’re supposed to ask about the arrows.
But what about the arrows? Thanks for asking!
These only appear on the solid lines of
the fermions, and they point forwards in
time for matter particles and backwards
in time for anti-matter particles.
Because weirdly, in particle physics, an
antimatter particle is exactly the same
as a matter particle that’s travelling backwards
in time. But where on my little picture are the
antimatter particles? Oh yeah, nobody ever
bothers to draw them on the standard model,
so I’ve done it here, here they all are.
There are antimatter copies of all these
particles, which have the same mass as the matter
versions, but opposite everything else.
And while we’re actually drawing actually all the
particles I may as well draw the different colour
charges of the quarks and the eight kinds of
gluons. These colours aren’t real by the way just
our labelling system for keeping track of
the rules of the strong force. So this is
actually all of the fundamental particles.
Goodness, there are a lot of rules aren’t there?
I’m sorry it’s all so complicated,
but that’s just life isn’t it?
So now we’ve covered part one and part two: what
the squiggly lines mean and what all the particles
are. This is enough to be able to read Feynman
diagrams and make sense of what is going on.
So let’s apply this knowledge
with some examples.
Here’s one we met earlier showing two electrons
interacting with a photon and is an example of
an interaction via the electromagnetic
force. Here are a couple more but these
are interactions involving the weak force and
here’s a couple involving the strong force.
You’ll notice that these are all a similar shape,
and I did that on purpose because I want to talk
about vertices. If you chop these in half you
get a vertex, which is basically a meeting point
between three particles, and you can think of
these vertices as the building blocks of Feynman
diagrams. You can build most feynman diagrams
out of this basis set of vertices, which I’m not
going to describe in detail now, but pause the
video now if you want to study them more.
What is interesting about these is that they
mean different things depending on how they
are oriented in space and time. For example, this
is an electron that has a change of momentum when
it emits a photon. But if I rotate it this
electron becomes a positron, remember that
rule about matter travelling backwards in time is
just antimatter travelling forwards in time. And
then this shows a positron and an electron coming
together to annihilate into a photon. So different
orientations can mean very different things.
So with this basis set of vertices put in
different orientations, you’ve got pretty much
all you need to build any feynman diagram.
Let’s look at some more complicated examples.
Here are the electrons interacting again, but
in the middle the photon spontaneously
turns into an electron positron pair,
before annihilating and turning
into a photon again.
See if you can work out what’s going on here? This
is a neutron, which is made of three quarks: up,
down, down. It decays into a proton via the weak
force. A proton is made of up, down, up quarks.
The w boson that is emitted then decays into
an electron and an anti-electron neutrino.
So this is how neutrons can turn into protons
via the weak force and is known in nuclear
physics as a beta decay emission.
This last one I’m going to leave to you
to disentangle. See if you can work out what is
going on here and specifically can you answer
which force is mediating this interaction? Let me
know in the comments below what you think..
Now you know how to read Feynman diagrams,
congratulations! But, we don’t yet know how
to analyse them to see if they are valid or not.
For that we need to learn the underlying rules the
particles follow called the conservation
rules of particle physics, but to avoid
information overload I’m going to cover that
in my next video, so stay tuned for that.
I recently watched a great documentary on quantum
physics on Magellan TV who are sponsoring this
part of the video. If you are outside the UK
you might not know Jim Al Khalili as he’s mostly
on british TV, but he’s a fantastic science
communicator and big inspiration to me when I
started this channel. And this is a brilliant
summary of the origins of quantum physics.
If you wanna watch it you can get it on a
free trial of Magellan TV, a new streaming
service founded by filmmakers, which has over
three thousand documentaries covering science,
technology, health, physics and
many other fascinating subjects.
It has over three thousand documentaries so far
and new shows are being added on a weekly basis
with a growing selection of shows available in 4K.
So if you want to check it out you can get a one
month free trial to see what you think at this
link which you can click on in the description
below, and this also helps me and my channel out
because they know you’ve come from here.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you
soon to delve deeper into this poster
of the standard model where we’ll lear the
third part of feynman diagrams where we
understand the underlying rules that the
fundamental particles follow. See you then.